Israeli forces are conducting one of the
largest raids in cities across the
occupied West Bank since the war in Gaza
began its forces have entered rala
Janine Hebron nablas and
taram these are pictures coming out of
ramala where clashes have broken out
several Palestinians and an Israeli
soldier have been injured the raids have
become an almost nightly occurrent since
October
7th well a paramedic in rala has
described some of the scenes that have
been taking place as he picked up some
of those injured in the
rids we treated and transported four
injured Palestinians who were shot in
the chest shoulder leg and sensitive
areas with 223 caliber rounds we were
able to get the injured to the hospitals
and two other injuries were transported
by our colleagues from the Palestinian
red crescent well Imran Khan joins us on
the phone now from rala in the occupied
West Bank Imran so we've seen this huge
increase increase uh in the scale and
tempo of Israeli military raids across
the West Bank overnight just talk us
through what you've been seeing and
hearing well the raids began around 1
a.m. in the morning um where I am is
called alad Street it leads into uh the
center of theala Manara Square where
actually alzer's office is based um at
1:00 a.m. in the morning they came the
Israeli forces came in they cleared the
area
uh using sound bombs sound grenades and
uh tear gas you could smell the tear gas
heavy in the air once they' done that
they actually then um surrounded and cut
off the streets uh to my hotel um and
then about an hour later uh they bought
in reinforcements and used this area
where I am uh directly in front of me as
the staging post uh for the raids that
then began um with much more intensity
in the center of rala what we're hearing
is the raids have been directed at money
exchange places uh you can probably just
hear another explosion in the background
uh there uh the money exchange places
the Israelis have long said have been
used by resistance groups to finance uh
their activities but they're also just
part and parcel of daily life in any big
city in the world uh but the size of
this raid is very unusual when the
reinforcements arrived I counted uh 20
armored vehicles uh that's a
significantly larger amount of armored
vehicles than we've seen in Rola in a
very very long time uh 16 of those
armored vehicles then went into where uh
the raids were taking place about half a
mile away from where I am as the crow
flies uh there was a huge explosion uh
around about 3:00 local time that
explosion we now know was against a
commercial property uh it was a
controlled explosion to enter into the
building where a money exchange place
was then raided we're hearing the owners
have been detained um and Records have
been taken um I've seen physically
myself um two Israeli Soldiers with a
very very large bag uh take that bag
into uh one of the vehicles as I'm
speaking to you right now um there are
six Israeli vehicles on the street but
they've actually changed Direction they
look like they're getting ready to
withdraw this raid is still ongoing
however as you heard clashes and and
explosions there in the
background um Imran since since October
7th it's worth uh pointing out we've
seen over 300 Palestinians killed
hundreds arrested by Israeli forces
across the West Bank what is Israel's
objective here in stepping up these
nightly
raids well Israel itself says the raids
are mounted against people who uh they
believe are part of the resistance so
they're going into places like n aam's
refugee camp Janine refugee camp they're
going into Al refugee camp in uh near
Hebron um and into Jericho as well and
they go in what they do it's very
typical and I've just described the
scene here in Rolo as well uh they go in
with lots of armed vehicles and lots of
soldiers on foot uh they then uh arrest
people uh 4,000 4,8 00 people have been
arrested since October the 7 at least
half of those are held without charge on
what's called administrative detention
so that's one of the the um raids
objectives however um in nasham Camp uh
in tarum I was there in the aftermath of
a drone strike that actually killed six
Palestinians now uh they were unarmed um
local residents told us they had no
history of being part of the Armed
resistance um the Israelis called the
militants um and said that that's the
reason they were attacked also in that
same raid a um Israeli soldier walked
into an ambulance and stabbed a
Palestinian in the neck whilst he was in
the ambulance um there was a scene that
was described as horrific by the
paramedic um who's now very worried
about retribution against him once he
reported that incident so these are the
raids that are going on this is the kind
of tactics that they the Israelis are
using 42 raids and knights that's now
the official figure um that's been given
by the Palestinian Authority that is a
far larger figure than we've seen uh
since before October the 7th before
October the 7th you may have seen one
two raids uh perhaps at night over
fairly shortly now the raids like I say
increasing in frequency 42 of them a
night on average then uh the raids are
actually taking place during the day
which never happened before also they're
taking a lot longer there was a raid
last week in Janine that lasted nearly
50 hours okay um isra um Imran just just
describe to our viewers what sort of
places are being targeted in these
Israeli raids I mean you mentioned uh
money exchange is being targeted what's
the thinking behind that and just
describe for us other places IND uals
that they're
hitting well the money exchange places
is unusual I have to say that's uh
something that I haven't really seen
before the Israelis have long said uh
that the resistance groups use the uh
money exchange places uh to finance
their activities uh but normally uh
these raids are part of an arrest
campaign across the occupied uh West
Bank now let's just take a look at what
that means remember during the ceasefire
there was a prisoner exchange done for
Israeli captives held by Hamas um the
amount of um of prisoners that they
released in that ceasefire Exchange in
the same period during the ceasefire
they arrested almost the same amount of
people so this is all about going in and
getting people um and arresting people
the arrest campaign is really what's
driving this this money exchange thing
here in the center of rala that is
actually a new tax on me U but we have
seen this in previous years uh and like
I said the Israelis do think that the
resistance groups use those uh money
exchange places to finance their
activities all right Imran Khan live for
us there in rala in the occupied West
Bank just updating us there on those
latest Israeli raids